are you doing Lisa how are you doing
this is a night where a superhero movie
could walk away with the biggest prize
and what does that mean to know that you
know these superhero movies now are
being nominated for Oscars I mean just
for all the artists behind it for visual
effects and cinematography for direction
I mean it's cool it's our it's our
modern mythology I just have you seen
the little Girl Scout who's selling the
Jason Momoa cookies a senator smoke
I love Girl Scout cookies I was like
waiting to get some free ones I love
some I think she would probably so you
want her to say I want the shortbread
and then di put that in the freezer
that's the way the best way you don't
want your own cookies well you heard him
Lisa you having fun tonight and is it
great watching him soak up all the love
and how well Aquaman
what's been the best part of it I mean
just like there's a little pressure
going in to do any kind of superhero
movie what has been the best part of it
for you being a part of that family
being part of the making superhero movie
I mean it's been nice just being a DC
and Warner Brothers and doing a good job
and that it's been a successful film I
mean I've been on it for five years with
the last three films and you know ups
and downs
now we up do you up feels like it feels
good to be the ones up alright go to the
20 years yeah that's the big deal that's
what I was saying you see a bunch here
tonight including you diversity I love
it we were in pink now it's the color of
the night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]